my name is Kathy white I'm a research
associate at the bio motion lab here at
Stanford we are interested in learning
about how walking patterns change with
different conditions either age disease
which jeje osteoarthritis ACL tears and
reconstruction we're supposedly language
enemy that's our main lab swing focus
and we want to know the relationship
between horses in that joint and how the
joint changes or whether it's helping at
all we have two tens of cameras one uses
official water based system which looks
at like the Falls place in the body
these markers have like a 3m light
reflective tape on the outside of them
and so with our cameras which have an
LED ring light around them it will flash
out reflect off of this is red back in
the camera sensor and then we can
calculate the 3d position of each of
these markers on the body in our
laboratory space the other systems
what we call markerless technology which
uses eight simple video cameras in order
to recreate person in space essentially
we have eight pictures as a person
around the room we then projectors all
together to create a volume that the
person occupies in space we then create
a model from our laser scanner and then
we fit that model to the person so using
that technology we can look at how the
person moves through space based on
their visual health and how the model
fits vegetable so when we create a
subject specific model we can then more
easily track the space that a person
occupies when they're walking through
our lab makes math a lot easier our labs
main focus is understanding knee
osteoarthritis osteoarthritis is
probably the biggest me disorder it
affects
ten percent of the world population I
believe it affects whether you can
get on and off bus whether you can walk
upstairs pick up your grandchildren and
it leads to depression and a whole host
of other things
you